Let's look at the answer to our quiz.
What kind of application gets no
benefit from miss-under-miss support?
One that always sits in
the cache gets no benefit.
It never has misses so it cannot
benefit from miss-under-miss support.
An application that misses every 1000
instructions will have a miss, and
the processor will run
out of ROB entries
because it has fewer than 1000
until it finds the next miss.
So that application will
suffer the first miss, and
only then the processor can continue and
find the next miss, so
we never actually need
to do miss-under-miss.
So, this application will not benefit.
An application that has a miss every
ten instructions will have a miss and
will find the next miss, so it can
benefit from a miss-under-miss support.
So, this should not be checked.
And then, an application that has a miss
every two instructions, of course, will
also benefit from a miss-under-miss,
so we don't check this either.